what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again to discuss the
latest
and possibly the craziest ever chapter
of boruto if you do enjoy seeing boruto
videos on this channel and want to keep
them coming the best thing you do is
smash that like button and share this
video with any fellow ninja that you
know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto and boruto videos let this
be the day you actually hit that
subscribe button if you haven't already
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
naruto slash boruto playlist where i got
videos about uchiha all hokage
all uzumaki all otsuki and more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and
all the cover here is epic we got both
naruto and boruto together
and the title is sacrifice which is
already crazy
we've been talking about how it doesn't
look good for naruto and sasuke at all
in this fight for the last few chapters
and this title not to mention this whole
chapter does not help matters at
all but let's read on we start where we
left off with boruto saying that ishiki
can't kill him and ishiki is not very
convincing when he tries to play it off
cool
clearly boruto is on to something boruto
then explains to sasuke that boro
when boruto fought him was going on
about some plan
and said that thanks to boruto the time
limit that was urgently pressing on
their plans
might as well have been lifted boro said
he'd take
boruto and treat him with care which is
a pretty good hint that boruto is
special to them as sasuke guesses boruto
is important for the divine tree that
ishiki wants to plant and as a result
he can't afford for boruto to die this
is very interesting stuff for a long
time naruto fan
and i'm glad it ended up being something
like this i was wondering last chapter
if maybe ishiki just didn't want to kill
boruto because he was hosting an
ottutsuki
and that is why but it's more
complicated it's not some otsuki rule or
respect among otsuki
it's because it serves ishiki's selfish
purpose and that's much more realistic
for his character and then we jump to a
motto and learn
even more interesting things about the
divine tree definitely cool info for any
naruto fan to learn
so amado says you can't just plant the
ten-tail
sapling in soil for it to grow into a
divine tree
for the ten tails to become a divine
tree you need to feed a living otsutsuki
to the ten tails
crazy and of course amado is his usual
super chill self as he's giving us this
groundbreaking information
we then jump back to ishiki who is
surprised that boruto could beat
boro but as we know it was with help
from momoshiki that boruto was able to
crush him and then
there is a funny part where sasuke
mentions that konoha already knows about
the divine tree ten tales
and why ishiki wants kawaki but ishiki
just says who cares when they don't have
any power for ishiki all the knowledge
in the world can't make up the power gap
between the two sides which is a pretty
big rhetorical flex right there then
boruto does something real crazy he puts
a kunai to his neck and says that if
ishiki moves
he won't hesitate to stab himself and
take away ishiki's important sacrifice
for the divine tree so you could say
that boruto is ishiki's most important
sacrifice but there's even more meaning
to that title than just that as we'll
see soon
then jumping back to cool calm scientist
amato he explains that otsutsuki come to
planets
in pairs because one is going to get
sacrificed for the tree
one gets eaten and the other watches
over the tree's growth until the chakra
fruit develops
however our motto points out that there
is karma so even if they sacrifice
themselves for the tree
they can prepare a vessel ahead of time
for resurrecting later
amado says that kaguya was lower rank
than ishiki
so she would have been the sacrifice
before she betrayed ishiki as a result
ishiki had to wait and go on with the
plan without her
before the boruto thing ishiki would
have had to eventually feed himself to
the tree but if he did that now with no
karma
he would die for good and so boruto is
his key
so that borto can be sacrificed while
ishiki ideally continues to watch over
the tree
and there's more to it but for now we
jump back to the epic fight despite
boruto telling ishiki not to move
he does and boruto doesn't stab himself
he shouts out and then ishiki shrinks
the weapon
so either ishiki was too fast or boruto
decide not to stab himself which being
honest is probably a pretty good choice
sasuke is hella worried here he knows
that they have no shot against ishiki
and so he just says that they have to
try to buy enough time
so that ishiki's body hopefully breaks
down this is a terrible situation for
these guys to be in
imagine risking your life just hoping to
last as long as possible
knowing you can't actually beat the
opponent unless he self-destructs
that's like goku's worst nightmare right
there and even this idea doesn't go well
in a split second ishiki kicks sasuke
into the ground
bro i can't remember the last time
sasuke looked so powerless
and that really lends to how strong
ishiki is what a beast
as if that wasn't enough he also drops
his giant cubes on him too
boruto recklessly tries to use that
asengon on this beast
but ishiki is not playing around anymore
sure he doesn't want to kill boruto but
he has
nothing against hurting him hurting him
bad and he just proceeds to break his
left arm
boruto is not untouchable and if he
provokes ishiki enough
yotsutuki might just break every limb in
boruto's body
so that he can't even move anymore and
although this is worrisome af for our
guys
it is kind of humorous how ishiki
apologizes for the misunderstanding to
bordeaux it's like ishiki is just like
bro you thought i couldn't touch you
no i can make you feel the worst pain
you can ever imagine
and it's good that you're prepared to
die because i will kill you by feeding
you to the ten tails eventually
ishiki is no joke and as far as enemies
go
he's a really good antagonist we jump
back to a model who says that from the
looks of it
boruto will become a complete otozuki
and a powerful one too
and that's important all chakra fruits
aren't created equal
a better healthier tree will produce a
better fruit so the fruit that would
come from young healthy boruto
is infinitely better than the one that
would come from jigen
a rotting corpse while people are
worried asking how borto can win
amato pulls a spiked spiegel from cowboy
bebop line
but instead of saying whatever happens
happens he says it'll go the way it goes
looking chill and smoking like spike too
although i enjoy a motto's character it
does rub some people the wrong way like
kawaki
who is pissed by amato's chill
expression kawaki does understand how
amado
who will be toast if naruto and sasuke
lose is being so calm
amato simply asks why kawaki is so
irritable a pretty epic response to
being grabbed angrily by the caller and
then amado reveals his philosophy
he simply makes what appears to be the
best choice available to him at the time
beyond that it's not in his control
there's nothing he can do so he doesn't
worry about it
and that aspect of a motto is very stoic
and i love it no matter what happens
amado is prepared to accept the results
of his choices
kawaki hates waiting and being powerless
anamato
asks is it powerlessness or grief over
losing his karma that irritates him and
this
is a very interesting question despite
akarma making you pretty much an
osutsuki time bomb it does give you
power
it makes you unique and special and as
ishiki himself said it can arguably
serve to fill the emptiness inside of
you
suddenly your aimless existence has a
purpose whether it is a good purpose
or bad purpose might not matter to some
people one thing's for sure though
kawaki does not like being powerless and
having to wait
he may well be envying boruto right now
who can use his karma in order to
increase his power and give him some
kind of fighting chance
against ishiki then naruto points out
that ishiki's giant cubes
are blocking his senses so he can't
locate
anyone this is at the same time the
saddest and most hyped part of the
chapter at the same time
naruto lets kurama know that he is ready
to die trying to hold off ishiki
and that he doesn't have any other plans
except dying
because naruto is going to give up his
life anyways kurama mentions an
ace they have up their sleeve which is
insanity
who would have expected naruto to get a
new power
or new form from kurama at this point i
thought the focus would be now on
boruto's upgrades but
no kurama straight up has a secret up
his sleeve
and he never brought it up before
because it will lead to death apparently
he tells arthur that he'll die if naruto
does this it's over kurama says
kurama is only bringing it up because
naruto is gonna get killed either way
from the looks of it
most people were suggesting sasuke would
die if anyone
but here they are actually making it
seem like naruto is the one more likely
to die
this is messed up and i don't want it to
happen and i kind of don't think it will
happen i feel like there might be a
loophole
or something down the line killing off
naruto would be an absolutely terrible
move
for the boruto series in my view and
send old fans in an uproar
and anime uproar but ignoring the
obviously horrible possibility of naruto
dying
the fact that we'll get a secret new
form is
pretty hype not gonna lie then we jump
to borto getting crushed below ishiki's
feet
he tells boruto not to despair because
the divine tree
will consume all life on this planet
anyways
so berto will just die a bit sooner than
the rest not exactly comforting words
for boruto but
important info that addresses something
from before why was the earth the only
planet not completely destroyed by the
divine tree
before it produced a chakra fruit and it
seems to be because
kaguya did not follow the rules properly
like ishiki is planning to do
this would produce a much much more
powerful chakra fruit
in theory which would make ishiki just
unimaginably
strong at that point if he ever ate it
that's the scary thing about ishiki he's
already flexing on
everyone everyone combined and he can
still get a kawaki body upgrade
and a chakra fruit upgrade after that
absolutely insane but not so fast you
horned alien
because naruto comes in and kicks him in
the face
saving his son i love these father-son
moments and they totally remind me of
gohan and goku's relationship and
although many people didn't like boruto
or still don't as a character
at least you know he's not gonna forsake
his training for studying in school
so i do like that about him my boy gohan
had so much potential before he became a
scholar
naruto tells boruto that he's the hokage
and not to worry about him a touching
moment
and the boruto series has never been
this intense
like ever we are right now experiencing
the peak of
boruto so far in my view naruto tells
kurama
he's ready and that he's been prepared
to die
since he decided he wanted to become
hokage and he pretty much
already decided this by the beginning of
naruto so there's so
much significance right here in this
moment he achieved his dream of becoming
hokage
and now he's willing to put his life on
the line because that is what being a
hokage means
and then we see a brand new epic looking
form
sasuke is shocked he's just been
vegetared
by which i mean he has to watch on
powerlessly while the main character and
his rival just pulled significantly
ahead
even ishiki is like what is this chakra
and to build even more hype around the
transformation
we only see a part of naruto's face in
this new epic form
wow the best boruto chapter this was
epic
and i absolutely can't wait to see what
happens next now what i thought would
happen
is that this transformation would be
super risky in that it might drain his
life force directly like esconds the one
ultimate mode
or that there would be a chance of him
dying but not 100
that would make more sense to me but
kurama straight up said that naruto will
die
and if he does this it's over so i don't
know what to think i'm so
torn on the one hand i don't want naruto
to die
obviously and i really don't think that
they would kill him off
but on the other hand they straight up
said that he'd die
so it doesn't get any more bad than this
unless a character
actually dies before your eyes for good
at the same time
i am hyped to see this new form and what
it is capable of but let me know what
you guys think
will naruto actually die is there even a
chance of that happening
and how strong will this form be and
that is it for this
absolutely insane mind-blowing chapter
thank you so much for watching if you
did enjoy this review and want to keep
the boruto reviews coming make sure to
smash that like button share this video
with any fellow ninja that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto and boruto videos
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my growing
naruto boruto playlist where i got
videos about to chiha
ahokage all zumaki all ototuki and more
link to that is in the description
thanks again and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you